[Music]
back in 2018 marvel spider-man released
on the ps4 and it was universally loved
resulting in many game of the year
nominations
now two years later spider-man is back
but this time peter is taking a back
seat and miles morales is our new hero
here's 20 things you need to know about
marvel spider-man miles morales
and welcome to playstation grenade let's
break down as much info as we can about
this
the first thing of note even though
marvel's spider-man mars morales is
being endorsed as a ps5 launch title
it's also here on ps4 so don't worry if
you were frantically trying to get a ps5
and failed
or if you simply have no plans to move
to the next generation yet
all is good spider-man mars morales is
on current gen 2 but there are a few
technical limitations we should cover
but we'll do that in a little bit let's
start with the story
just over 12 months have passed since
peter's heroics in manhattan
we are back this time it's past autumn
and the winter season is kicking in
miles is training under the tutoriage of
peter parker to be the second spider-man
and slowly uncover his abilities peter
is called away on a photography mission
in cincaria leaving miles to defend the
city
alone of course things don't stay calm
for long and the bad guys of the story
are revealed the evil roxon corporation
are battling against a new faction known
as the underground
led by the villain the tinkerer if you
haven't heard of the tinkerer here's a
few things of note
he was one of spider-man's original
enemies in the 1960s but changed many
times over the years
right now he's seen as the brilliant
technician and inventor
who comes up with the weird and
wonderful weaponry used by a ton of
spider-man's foes
in this version of spider-man it looks
like the tinkerer is becoming more
hands-on again
and getting involved in the action
instead of staying out of sight
he's not the only one though of course
other villains will be popping up
like rhino who is back to be the early
game boss
i think it's important to make the point
that marvel spider-man miles morales
is not a full-length game like the 2018
outing
insomniac have made it very clear and
tell us to think of this
similarly to uncharted the lost legacy
which was a stand-alone addition which
did not require the original game to run
so effectively this is way more than dlc
a standalone story
the assumption is mars's story will take
about 15 hours to complete
with collectibles and random events
altering that time frame for many gamers
this leads on to my next point there are
two versions of the game the standard
edition is for those who only want mars
morales in their life and nothing more
but the second version should grab your
attention and that's due to it being
bundled with the original game which has
been remastered
and strangely that includes a new peter
parker looking like a chubby tom holland
but that's not the main focus here this
ultimate version is bundled with
all the dlc expansions from the original
game
let's be honest most of us do not pick
up dlc for games did you play it
some of us me included by the dlc but by
the time it is released
we've moved past that game and onto new
things sad but true
the reason why those dlcs are important
is because they include
early parts of miles and historic
without spoilers
something earth-shattering happens to
miles in the 2018 game
before tiny pieces of info are given out
in the dlcs which build up to his moment
in the spotlight
those who are here for story should
really consider playing the remastered
story to get the full narrative arc
for miles morales think of it this way
in 2018
miles was running and hiding from rhino
whereas in 2020
he's going head to head with the brute
it's pretty impactful
one thing i've noticed around the
interweb is the claim that miles is
simply a reskin of the original game
like we've already said he has his own
story arc it's like a coming of age
superhero story
and on top of that miles has his own
animations such as
his swinging technique and his fighting
style so i think we can rest this to bed
this is more than a reskin
if you need more evidence well check out
miles and his new abilities
if you've seen into the spider-verse
which is loki the best spider-man movie
ever made and i'll fight you in the
comments if you disagree
miles miles has two abilities like no
other
firstly a venom strike no not the venom
you're thinking of
but miles has faced venom in the comic
books but let's stay on point here
mar's version of venom strike is like
bioelectricity
which he can pass through with touch the
shock can simply stun the opponent
or with enough charge it can take out a
super villain
and even peter parker mile's second
ability is a stealth camouflage in which
he becomes transparent
and almost invisible luckily his clothes
become invisible too that could be
awkward
in game this is a core mechanic which
runs on a cool down
and is not endless we can use it to
reposition in a fight for a takedown
or simply hide when things get too
hectic
miles is his own spider-man and fights
his own way
another returning element are those
gadgets which are pivotal to gameplay
and replayability
we don't know too much about gadgets
right now and how they impact mars's
fighting style
and that's probably for the best finding
a new gadget and using it in battle
is great fun we have seen one though the
gravity well
any ideas what this could do i can't
wait to find out
while we're talking about customizing
spider-man another returning bit of
brilliance is here
miles is his own man he has his own
personality his own heritage
and that's why he won't be wearing
peter's attire for too long
during your playthrough you'll unlock
mars's signature black spider suit
but that's just the beginning we've seen
a hint to a futuristic suit
we've seen the crimson cowl on its hood
and the suit which is likely impossible
to keep clean
the t-r-a-c-k suit the track suit
get it lol and then the suit which makes
lovers of the spider-verse movie
very happy here it is he is wearing that
exact suit from the movie the animated
style carries over and includes
a new set of animations ported over to
the video game the thing which made me
unbelievably happy is the animation
style just like in the movie the suit is
animated on alternated frames on the
twos they call it
which is why it looks like it lags or
moves differently
it's trippy at first but becomes really
lovable just another example of how much
love is going into this game
i wasn't sure where to put this next
point as i don't know if this is a
gadget
or a suit but there is a spider cat in
the game
he even has his own takedown moves to
help out miles
look at his mask cute little bugger so
now we have to get a little technical
here's a few key differences between the
ps5 and the ps4 versions of marvel
spider-man mars morales
firstly that overused word ray tracing
is here
as you'd likely know ray tracing is the
way light illuminates a scene and
impacts shadows and reflections and
that's not available on the ps4 version
it's a very heavy process
so if you need realistic puddle
reflections
you should get out more now i mean you
should play on the ps5
but even on the ps5 ray tracing comes at
a cost
let's fly through it with ray tracing
switched on the ps5 version can still
support 4k
output but only 30 frames per second
compare this to performance mode which
gives us 60 frames per second
and still at 4k but that pushes aside
the ray tracing element
over on the ps4 standard edition you'll
get 30 frames per second at 1080p
and on the ps4 pro you can rock up to 4k
and still hold on to 30 frames per
second i'm very keen to not make this
too technical
let's simmer it down if you want 60
frames every second you'll be forced to
switch off ray tracing
on ps5 a tough call for some other
differences on the ps5 are primarily
with load times
the crazy fast ssd in your ps5 can
thanos snap
load times whereas the ps4 version will
obviously take a little longer
the ps5 controller will include haptic
feedback which
is incredibly hard to explain but
ultimately
the game will be more immersive for
those who have access to a dual sense
controller
in tough moments the triggers will fight
back to simulate the on-screen struggles
of miles
it's pretty impressive tech and there
should also be a change in the audio
on ps5 there's new audio tech in there
which is supposedly more well-rounded
and directable
which mimics ray tracing and the
bouncing of audio from surfaces
i haven't personally heard it yet so i
can't speak too confidently about audio
to be honest i've been waiting 20 years
for audio to be improved in video games
is the ps5 the key to this i suppose
we'll wait and see
and finally unlike the 2018 game
insomniac have gone on the record to
state
we will only play as miles in marvel's
spider-man mars morales
if you remember the original game we
occasionally played as mj
in stealthy missions and we played as
miles to escape missions and we even
played as standard peter parker in some
story missions
this time around it's all about miles oh
and one more thing
if like me you've played the original on
ps4 and want to transfer your save data
to the ps5 it has been confirmed to be
possible
no need to start again if you don't want
to which is useful to hear isn't it
i'm still totally starting again just to
try out the new peter parker and what he
looks like
marvel spider-man miles morales is a
bloody long title isn't he releases on
ps5 and ps4 on november 12th
although some of us will need to wait
for the ps5 to release
on november 19th to play the next gen
version i'm sure i'll be hiding from
spoilers all that week
i'm adam from playstation grenade thank
you for sticking around this long you're
awesome i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you